北
特異な日本語でおしゃべりします
as pinky voce
ok 前まきわーる today ずおしゃべり
あおしゃべり is アパ村フライス2とカラー
q おしゃべり is to とカロ
ok
web さん
この中で
おしゃべりが好きだしたぁーいうん方などもいっぱいいる
じゃあ
おしゃべりして先生に注意されたことアリスはーい
むちゃくちゃいっぱいじゃないですかのゴムボッカあります
僕が
高校の固定の授業で
先生に言われた言葉
これです
なブツかっ
お願いだから
寝てくれ8
ふぇぇ寝てくれやっぱいおしゃべりすぎた
めちゃくちゃ怒ってる
でもねぇ北
おしゃべり大好きなのです
僕は
プロギャンブラーです
世界を
15年かけて勝負で勝ちカジノ勝負で勝ち続けて
リョウク周してきました
5年前
震災の時ボランティアしに帰ってきましたその時は中学高校の時のもともとの友達しか
ありませんでした
それがこの5年間で
例えば
芸能界にスカートされたり
テレビに10回以上でたり
安倍総理の前座時間にプレゼンしたり
2冊本だしたり
もうね夢が夢が叶うまくってるんです
意味わかんないくらい
僕が行きたかった所になぜかたどり着けている
まさしくここがユートピア
日本語で言えば理想郷
なぜ僕がこのユートピアにたどり着けたのか
なんでだろうって考えてで出てきた答えそれが原因
おしゃべりおしゃべりのおかげなんです
つまりおしゃべりっていうのは悪かったんじゃないんです
むしろおしゃべりしたほうが良かったんです
今日の僕のテーマを発表します一緒にドラムお願いします
出れるレベルがありがとうございます
じゃん
おしゃべりはユートピアを作る
これねみんなで一緒に行ってほしいですお願いしますせーのなぁとでいきますよせーの
おしゃべりは
言っ
フィートピアーを作る結構ゆっくりだね皆上はもう1回ゆっくり子星のおしゃべりは
ユートピアを
スクールありがとうます
ます
去年おしゃべりのメリット3つ
際に来ました
一つ目前店
学生時代いい
大事な事ってあるんですけど
勉強だけじゃないんです大人になってわかったこと他にもめちゃくちゃ大事なことが
あるんです
それが1個目店
友達づくり
学生時代はおしゃべりしまくって友だち作りまくって
卒業をいろんなことを相談できたり
かけがえのない仲間になるから
一生の財産だから
もし今いじめとかしてたらその一生財産一生の財産を手放すことになっちゃう
だからこそ僕ねいじめというのは絶対お勧めしないでこんな
ウィンって感じで悲しい感じの人生になっちゃいます
そして
僕の話に戻します僕は同級生高校の時152言いました
その152とみんなね1人ひとりと会話してたんです
そうすると何が起こるかというとこの人の夢
この人の好きなことこの人が今までした経験色々教えてもらった
そして僕がおしゃべりして学んだこと
すごい大事なことですこれ
他人は自分より上の部分を持っている
大事なことにいる言っちゃうよ他人は自分より上の部分を持っているんです
つまりその素敵な部分というヒントをおしゃべりして得て着るんです
そして
素敵な部分を知ったときどういう行動すればいいか
これが
てピカーンティーピ ptp の意味わかる方いらっしゃいます
これねちょっとわかりにくいと思いますあわかりません
[音楽]
幕恋 ok あらそうです
徹底的に ttp 徹底的に博麗
子達ですよ皆さんご一緒にいきますよせーの ttp
徹底的にパクれ全然読む客6火星の ttp
設定的にパクヘあざす
人はねぇ
一人で素敵な人になんかなれないんです
でもいろんな人とおしゃべりして素敵な部分を知って素敵な部分を ttp でパクり
まくって組んでそしたら素敵な人になれるんです
おしゃべりっていうのはあなたの人生をペンいって加速してくれる
おしゃべりはあなたをユートピアな人に連れてってくれる
2個目おしゃべりのメリットいきます前店
夢が叶う
叶うて感じは
口と中で成り立っています10回おしゃべりをしたら夢が叶えやすいよっていう昔から
の教え
ヒントなんですでもぼく年ぶっちゃけ10回じゃ無理だって考えてます100回
100回僕は夢おしゃべりした時ほとんど
かなってきているんです
その100回話すと100人の人が僕に
例えばアドバイスしてくれたりとか例えばコネクションを繋いでくれたりとか
どんどん夢が叶う可能性が高くなっていくんです
例えばです僕この4年間毎週いろんなところでトーク依頼を頂いてました
僕はいつも小中校でも話したいんですって
よく言ってました
でもぼく言ってもギャンブラーです小中校は全然 ok だしてくれない
悲しい事にでもねそういうふうにぼくがずっと居続けしたらみんながこう
一生懸命ヘルプして協力してコネクションをつないでくれて
先月
4年越しの思いでなんとおそらくそれに日本初だと思います
ギャンブラーが小学校で遠く海派中
そうねこれは夢かなぁと思わなかったぶっちゃけ
[拍手]
ちなみにです
6名小学生にギャンブルって言っていませんもちろん
は言えなかったですめちゃくちゃ鈍くしてめちゃくちゃトランプが強い人って言いまし
た
油本当ですか
でもう一個
僕が
自分が死んだ後でも
残せる遠く思いそんなステージを目指して
選んでたのがこの手で x です
本件でやってました
僕100かいは
テレックスで未来へ伝えたい
そう言ってました
そしたらなんと今ギャンブラーがこのてレックスの舞台デー
さらになんですさらに
僕が伝えたかった中高生
初めてですぼくおしゃべりできているんですもうめちゃくちゃうれしい
だってギャンブラーがてデックスとか
ギャンブラーが中高生とかこれ両方ともね
2つ今日本初だと思います
2つの日本発が今重なってルアー重なっている
それは
正直でミラクルな瞬間なんでしま
ミラクルな瞬間でもそれは何でできたかそれは協力してくれた友達仲間
そしててでくスタッフ
このねみんなのおかげなんすおしゃべりして皆が繋がってみんなが協力してくれた
おかげ
ただまぁてベックスといっても幼稚園の子にボコお伝えするときは
おしゃべりだよって言うと思います
つまり
ごめんなさい
夢をおしゃべりしてたら
おしゃべりする夢までかなったんです
おしゃべりっていうのはあなたをユートピアねどんどんどんどん近づけてくれます
ここでおしゃべりのコツをひとつお伝えします
まず
おしゃべりな人イメージして友だち言うでしょイメージてください
いきますよそしてきまーすはい ttp
徹底的にばプレイこれみんなご一緒にいきますよせーの
p 2
ep
徹底的に1博麗話す
もうねドーンの徹底にパクってるス自分の足りない部分
そうするとこう真似して来演じて来
少しずつ一言喋れるようになっていくそしておしゃべりな人に慣れているか
3つ目ラストです僕のおしゃべりのメリット
世界平和
少しトーン改定
世界のシリアスな問題話させてください
僕は小さな頃からなんだよこれ意味わかんねーって思ってたことがあるんですそれが
なぜ紛争という名の人殺しがー
行われているの
僕は
ギャンブラーになったひとつの理由は世界をさせられるからで世界を見れるから
こんな感じで赤いところ回ってきています
15年かけて6周しているのに白いところ
行きにくい国っていうのがあったんです
それはなぜかというと
昨年だけで31か国も扮装しているんです
昨年だけで16万7千人もの人が紛争で殺されているんです
今僕が15分のスピーチをしていますこの15分の間に
後に入っ
5人の人が紛争で殺されているんです
自分の
大事な5人
思い浮かべてください家族
友達好きな人
その後に
その後人が
紛争で殺された
納得いかんショー
でもその納得に単勝って叫びが15分ごとに世界のどこかで起こっているんです
問題を解決するとき
紛争での人殺しと
とも大を車おしゃべりして
ハイテクのと
どっちがいいかそんな聞くまでもないでしょ
おしゃべりでしょおしゃべりの会議とかが良いでしょう
そんなね簡単な問題小学生でも判断できる簡単な問題が大人は解決できてないんです
正直で
大人って青かって思う
yeah line
汗所
大人ってねこう子供に学生に勉強しろ勉強しろ
言うけど
お前が勉強しわー
大人のお前が動けよ a
いつも思ってた
まぁ大人がね支えられないなら
僕は僕で考えて動いてこそだって生きてきた
人は環境によって作られます
自分が欲する人間になるにはどんな環境がいいかな
世界平和
人殺しからおしゃべり会の変革
そのためには
おかねぇ
くださいそのためにはまず僕が強くなること
そして勝ち方を知ることさらに世界を知ること
この3つを得れるかなーと思って
プロギャンブラーを目指しましたところもあります
勝負の世界に入ってわかったことは
想像を絶する厳しさでした
15年間ほとんど休んでないです
常に孤独2カ月間誰とも喋らないとか
常に勉強1日12時間とか
常に勝負食うか食われるかの厳しいせ media
辛すぎて
厳しすぎて
ストレスでツバにいつも血が混じってて
でも
僕が欲する能力のためには
諦めるなぁ
俺がんばれ
あってでも前へ進め
自分でいつもそう言い聞かせて
そして15年かけてようやく自分の欲しい能力
今手に入れたって考えています
ユートピア待ってても来ないことを知ったんです
いう時は待っててくるならもうすでにきているはずです
1年まるまる紛争がない年とか
そんな[ __ ]1年一切ないです
攻撃は最大の防御です
ユートピア勝ち取りに行くんです奪い取りに行くんです
ほとんどの人がみんなと同じように
紛争での人殺しよりおしゃべりでの解決を望んでいるんです
今インターネットでどんどん人がつながっています
おしゃべりして sns とかでみんなで紛争より
おしゃべりでの会議がいいじゃんっていう力をどんどんどんどんどんどんつなげていっ
て団結していけば今なら
世界変えられるんです
ごめんなさいおしゃべりが
紛争を無くせるんです
おしゃべりはユートピアを作れるんです
最後に一つ質問させてください
おしゃべりとかして
自分のユートピア
世界のユートピア
作ってみたいなぁと言うとはーいっ
うれしい
嬉しいです
ぜひ
ぜひ一緒に
ユートピア
作りましょう
まーす
[拍手]